what is a beautiful foundational
interesting idea to you a view quake in
the space of political science
the main thing that goes wrong in
politics is people
not agreeing on what the best thing to
do is
that's the wrong thing so that's what
goes wrong that is when you say what's
fundamentally behind most political
failures it's that people are ignorant
of what the consequences of policy is
and that's surprising because it's
actually feasible to solve that problem
which we aren't solving so it's a bug
not a feature that there's a
there's a
inability to arrive at a consensus
so most political systems if everybody
looked to some authority say on a
question and that authority told them
the answer then most political systems
are capable of just doing that thing
but
that is uh and so it's the failure to
have trust for the authorities
yeah that is sort of the
underlying failure behind most political
failure we failed we have bad we invade
iraq say when we don't have an authority
to tell us that's a really stupid thing
to do
it's it's and it is possible to create
more informative trust for the
authorities that that's a remarkable
fact about the world of
institutions that we could do that but
we aren't yeah that's that's surprising
we could and we aren't right another big
view crick about politics is from the
elephant the brain that most people when
they're interacting with politics they
say they want to like make the world
better they make their city better their
country better that's not their priority
what is it so if they want to show
loyalty to their allies they want to
show their trouble they're on their side
yes well they're various tribes they're
in that's that's their primary primary
priority and they do accomplish that
yeah and the tribes are usually
color-coded conveniently enough
um
what would you say
you know it's the churchill question uh
democracy is the the crappiest form of
government but it's the best one we got
what's the best form of government for
this
our
7 billion human civilization and the
maybe as we get farther and farther you
mentioned a lot of stuff that's
fascinating about human history as we
become more forager-like
and looking out beyond what's the best
form of government in the next 50
hundred years as we become a multiple
terrorist species so
the the key failing is that
we have existing political institutions
and related institutions like in media
institutions and other authority
institutions and
these institutions sit in a vast space
of possible institutions yes and the key
failing we're just not exploring that
space
so i have made my proposals in that
space and i think i can identify many
promising solutions and many other
people have made many other promising
proposals in that space but the key
thing is we're just not pursuing those
proposals we're not trying them out on
small scales we're not doing tests we're
not
exploring the space of these options
that is the key thing we're failing to
do and if we did that
i am confident we would find much better
institutions than when we're using now
but we would have to actually try
so a lot of those topics um i do hope we
get a chance to talk again you're a
fascinating human being so i'm skipping
a lot of tangents on purpose that i
would love to take you're such a
brilliant person on so many different
topics
you